your daughter left school she decided
she didn't want to finish college is
that right I tried to talk her out of it
but I dropped out of school and so did
her mother so I was like you want to
wind up like me all day long with your
friends making jokes eating Chinese food
and you will meet Beyonce okay which
begs the question have you met Beyonce
Beyonce I have a weird I do it I have a
weird
Beyonce story which is I went to see
Beyonce and jay-z which was amazing is
anyone seen that concert maybe maybe is
like as good as a show guest right and
so we're like blown away and afterwards
someone was like hey do you want it
there's a laughter party do you want to
stop in and I did and I'm very
uncomfortable I just feel like the goofy
Jew in the corner and it's just like
Chris Martin's there and Kobe Bryant and
I'm just like in the corner scared and
then jay-z walked in the room and he
walked straight to me and he goes oh my
god knocked up that scene when your wife
says doorman doorman doorman that's my
favorite scene of all time and he turns
to some guy next time he's like what do
we watch last week the guys like knocked
up man became your height and I became
like the coolest guy in the room and
then he said this to me which blew my
mind he goes can you not leave because
Beyonce's coming and if she doesn't get
to meet you and your wife she'll be mad
at me so that means if I left I could
have caused a marital problem there
could have been a song about that
a whole album oh yeah that's fantastic
so did you what happened did you well
what happened was I was nervous and
Beyonce would walk in and be like I
never saw knocked up like I was I
thought it would end very badly but if
then she walked in and was equally as
excited and walked up to my wife and
gave her a big hug and was like oh my
god
that's my favorite movie that's my
favorite scene in the movie you with
Craig Robinson and and then suddenly
director Jon Favreau walked over right
and I guess they just worked together
and he's like hey baby how's it going
and he starts talking to her and talking
to her and never lets her come back to
us he blocked it with Beyonce yes I was
furious I read the room I'm having a
moment here so the next morning I get up
and I'm talking to my daughter at
breakfast and I'm like Jon Favreau if
she's like dad you know what I don't
care that I didn't meet Beyonce cuz I
love her so much that it could only have
ruined it in some way I'm glad because
she's still perfect in my mind and I
thought I'm a good parent or something
like what what is this angel that
respective yeah you know what you're
wrong
screw Jon Favreau yeah so it's not cool
what have we bonded what if we went out
to dinner what if they liked us at
dinner they're like hey you want to go
to the Greek islands and go on a boat
with us and our friends Michelle and
Barack Obama
we'll go tomorrow
[Applause]
I'm mad at him now too